talk to me about nofap
i i think the online space
has got this like
different perception of what it is in my
opinion i think a lot of people think
like it is you know the levitation and
it's going to make you amazing and
everything and you certainly will see a
very very significant change in your
life if you're one of those like
hardcore bankers who like who are going
multiple times a day messed up porn and
everything which to be honest like
there's a fair amount of guys and i have
the authenticity to say yeah 100 i was
not that messed up but like i was one of
those guys right and so when you go from
this like multiple times a day to like
not maybe let's say once every three
days you're masturbating there's quite a
big difference and that's like i think
as far as a lot of the benefit does go
after that there's like this again this
cult online which is telling you okay if
you if you ever touch a dick again like
that's that's the perception that
they're pushing on to young young men if
you fap again you've lost the benefits
which that that blows my mind because
that's so unhealthy to tell young guys
it's like telling a beast guy okay yeah
get get into the gym get into the gym
you should go every day if you miss a
day you lose all of the progress
that's that's heartless man that's so
like
i've come across more young men who have
been pained by nofap than who have just
like got problems with like masturbation
yeah because they get like this
this um
existential crisis where now they feel
like more of a loser because they keep
failing nofap and it's just like simple
habit science that's how i always ask
them the question like when when did you
start checking off and they'll say you
know age 13 they're 19 right now
so six years you've been building up
this habit you found nofap a few weeks
ago six years you've been building it up
and you just think you're gonna break
the habit just like that it's like at
least for me it took me about five years
to get onto like no fap where like i
just it's honestly like it's not in my
life at all i don't even think about it
i often forget that porn and
masturbation is the thing but i was so
hard on myself for the first like year
or so thinking like i should get to day
90 or something because it's not just
about like you know the discipline and
willpower it's about like we've been
building up this habit for like 10 years
and it's like it's gonna take some time
to like reduce it down i wonder how many
people would benefit from nofap that
aren't like
pathological fappers
the people who aren't completely
addicted and see it as a vice because
one of the things that i've realized
recently is that with a lot of the
things we do that we don't like
ourselves for doing let's say it's using
our phone too much or maybe it's junk
eating on a night time or whatever it
might be
i would say that
less than 50 of the problem is the
actual activity that you do
and most of the problem comes from the
story that you tell yourself about the
type of person you are for having done
that action so a lot of the benefits
that i think we get from going through
any type of personal development
actually comes from a reframing around
capturing our own agency to do with that
particular action do you know what i
mean
yeah very very well said that's like
it's like this bell curve where at first
you don't really think that the original
thing is the problem the vice is the
problem so masturbation or let's say the
junk food eventually you start to see
people talk about you know quitting it
and everything okay this is when you
hate the thing you hate the thing but
you can't stop it and so there's often
this
negative
mental well-being
stage when you're trying to start a new
which everyone kind of knows which is
like when you finally start thinking
okay i've got to go to the gym got to
lose weight i've got to do this it's
like you just feel like [ __ ] for a
little while because you hate the thing
but you still have a habit or even an
addiction to the thing
and
you've actually brought up like a
fantastic point recently i've been
thinking that potentially the best way
to actually improve things like this
whether it's no fap or healthy and it's
actually way more about the self-image
and like the beliefs that we have about
ourselves more than it actually is you
know like the stereotypical advice of
like oh like you know install the
website blocker and like don't buy the
junk food and everything because
if you're just kind of like hide the
stuff away from you like it's like a
child just saying i can't i can't see
the pond anymore so i can't be addicted
or like you know i didn't buy the junk
food so i can't eat it anymore but it's
it's more
if you me and you have a chocolate bar
in front of us right now we're probably
not gonna eat it because it's just it
doesn't really align with our identity
we're going to think oh it's just not i
don't want to put it onto my fitness pal
and just have the regret there like oh
yeah 400 calories for a month for
yourself man
at the moment i can eat whatever the
[ __ ] i want
i had charlie hooper from charisma on
command on the show earlier this week
and uh we were talking about the fact
that there is a tension
between
assisting yourself to not do the things
that you don't want to do by hiding them
away from you or by creating constraints
in your life so you don't play league of
legends so you snap the game in half and
delete your xbox account or whatever and
there is a question
look i know that you're not a gamer
because you just said that
any gamers who's listening to you right
now
is it pc only
the problem that you have
is that
there is a part of you that feels
defeated by that like oh i'm defeatist
because
i've assisted so the same as you saying
like look
is keeping the junk food out of the
house actually putting a blinker over
your eyes so that you can't deal with
the underlying problem that's causing
the junk eating in the first place i
would be tempted to say that you need to
give yourself assistance in the first
place like environment design is a huge
part of habit building and it's probably
the case that the tools you get
in the beginning that get you across the
first river
isn't the boat that you're supposed to
carry across land to get you across the
second river it's like look the thing
that you did that got you here isn't the
thing that's going to get you there so
if you decide to assist yourself by
putting a
pawn blocker on your laptop or getting
rid of all the junk food out of your
house or doing whatever it might be
that's fine and then
that will allow you to at least gain
some momentum when your ability to stick
to the habit is its weakest
then we start to build up we start to
build up okay now i've got a bit more
capacity i've got a bit more capacity
and now maybe i can look to reintroduce
looking at where does my compulsion
to eat junk food on an evening come from
oh it's actually because i'm bored
because i don't have anything to do
maybe it's because i'm lonely oh well
now that i've given myself room away
from the junk food i can actually start
to fill that with something else
that's a really really good point
actually yeah so the original uh
environmental design i often critique it
i often say even though every like
scientist disagrees with me they say you
know like willpower is limited i'm like
i feel like i'm the one guy right now
telling everyone rely on willpower
instead because
like in my story like the environmental
design would never even work because
it's this idea okay i can not buy the
junk food inside the store
but then we've we've already got some at
home i can okay i'll throw it all out
you know it's one of those i'm going on
a diet i'm going to throw out the junk
food but then like my girlfriend's going
to come back home with like extra food
or i go to to work and it's like it's a
customer service job at the time so like
[ __ ] are bringing in like a lot
of snacks and stuff so me in that so
it's like if the idea is like you're
going to say no once inside of the shop
the thing is if if all you have is the
environmental design you probably aren't
going to manage the entire environment
around you whereas it really is that
level of willpower and even like the
self-image the belief that any given
time like we we have junk food in the
house all the time i finally love that
[ __ ] but like i walk past the kitchen no
problem every like every single day for
like two years there's the stuff that i
used to binge eat on but the reason why
is because i always try to do this thing
of like no no don't go into the kitchen
like tell my dad not to buy the crisp
eventually i
just it's kind of like psychopathic but
i got my favorite snacks just set them
on the desk and just looked at them and
i don't think many people have done this
but like
ah
the weird thoughts that you get about
yourself when you do that like seriously
get the best snacks that you've ever
gotten even drugs as well so i did this
with weed and i just put it on top of
the table just with like a notepad side
journaling
and it just makes you feel like a
crackhead because you're like oh like
you know like okay the experiment's
right
writing a [ __ ] ode to my drugs
i've written a poem i'm outside of its
window with a pair of roses
the boombox in there
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace